[чоловік свистить]
Не дуже хочеться до них іти,
аби вони краще прийшли до нас.
[чоловік свистить]
Що ж ви мене — старого чоловіка — змушуєте?
Мені здається, що я знаю менше
про них, ніж на початку.
Це завжди щось нове,
кожен із них має свій характер,
свої настрої, свій типаж поведінки.
І це завжди цікаво.
Я в 14 років на заколядовані гроші
два місяці ходив у секцію верхової їзди,
поки не закінчились ці гроші.
І на тому було все, потім просто ніхто...
У батьків не було грошей на такі секції,
була музика.
Щось таке.
Потім інститут.
Я чисто випадково потрапив на конюшню,
де попросився сісти на коня,
і воно так якби запустило знову механізм:
по-маленьку, по-маленьку.
Це Адя, Аделаїда — це, так звана,
спонтанна покупка була.
Мене друзі попросили поїхати
до одного чоловіка, який осликів розводить,
купити їм осла, а я поїхав, купив два.
І так Адя тут залишилася,
її всі страшно люблять.
Але все, що ви знаєте про ослів,
які маєте стереотипи — це все про Адю. Так?
Вони дуже вперті.
Оця сіренька тут, або,
як кажуть по правилах, сіро-чала —
це грудка гуцульської породи,
і це мій другий кінь.
Її, власне, я купив для того,
щоб вона займалася з дітьми іпотерапією у Львові.
І вона дала старт цьому проєкту.
Потім і Зюська, і Латка,
і ще є Кептарик у нас такий коник.
Всі вони з дітьми займались,
і займаються дотепер.
Іпотерапія — це метод реабілітації,
за допомогою коня,
і він полягає в тому, що їдучи верхи,
людина підсвідомо починає повторювати рухи коня.
Я як їду Трістаном, мені вистачить подумати,
що я зараз хочу праворуч поїхати, чи ліворуч,
і мозок відсилає сигнали моїм м'язам,
що, наприклад, я зараз повернуся,
і ці ж самі сигнали
відбирає кінський мозок через його тіло.
Це Трістан — мій перший кінь,
це більше ніж кінь.
По-перше, він мені як брат,
по-друге, він — мій партнер,
бо ми з ним разом ведемо табун.
Він керує кобилами,
він є авторитетом.
Тобто, якщо коні бояться якоїсь перешкоди,
і не хочуть перейти через якесь болітце
чи через якийсь рівчак,
якщо це робить Трістан, то всі за ним
спокійно цю перешкоду долають.
На конях ми працюємо
з професійними реабілітологами,
а діти, сідаючи на коня,
забувають про свою проблему.
Набагато легше працювати з дітьми,
коли вони сидять верхи,
тому що їхня увага тоді зосереджена на їзді.
Спеціалісту краще з ними працювати.
Але найважливіше, я взагалі вважаю,
що це психологічний ефект цієї штуки.
Ви собі уявіть, що дитинка має десять років,
її десять років мнуть, гнуть. А?
І, звичайно, що вони не хочуть,
їм це не подобається.
А тут вони сидять на хребті величезної тварини,
і ця тварина їх несе.
Вони є вище від усіх,
вони вперше, може,
навіть бачать так високо всіх інших.
Я також тебе дуже люблю, але я говорю.
Ну от, він точно буде з дітьми працювати.
Хаскі, бо має голубі очі.
Це мрія!
Коні були в мені з дитинства, як виявилось.
Воно не мало нагоди ніяк вилізти на поверхню.
Я народився в місті,
мої батьки, фактично, народилися в місті,
в нас ніколи не було села.
Я закінчив факультет міжнародних відносин університету,
але ніколи не працював за спеціальністю.
Потім відкрив своє швейне підприємство,
яке й досі працює.
Ким я був? Бізнесменом був?
Напевно, і залишився. Чи як? Не знаю.
Загалом це мали бути кінні походи,
але з часом це стало Скарбовою горою.
Я вважаю, що це трошки більше,
ніж просто походи.
Я почав їздити на коні,
я себе фантастично почав почувати.
Вичитав, що є така штука, як іпотерапія,
я вирішив, що хочу цим займатися
або дати таку можливість.
Я випадково натрапив на хатку,
яка є тут за горбом, по-маленьку почав у ній жити.
Потім мені вдалося
домовитися з громадою,
і мені виділили тут землю,
і я почав будувати ранчо.
Спочатку збудував хатку,
в якій сам почав жити.
Там на горі є два сарайчики, це були перші два сараї,
куди я привів своїх перших двох коней.
А 2013 року почали будувати цю велику  споруду.
Насамперед збудували конюшню,
щоб коні мали де жити,
а потім вже почали по-троху
закінчувати з гостьовим будинком.
Коні живуть тут тільки взимку,
і то переважно вночі
або хіба якась дуже негода.
А так коні в мене постійно
на вулиці, на пасовищі.
Взагалі дуже цікава процедура:
домовитися з конем співпрацювати.
Коні більше реагують не на звуки,
а на рухи і на поставу людського тіла до себе,
на спосіб, на дистанції.
Зовсім інша мова
і дуже цікаво, коли починаєш розуміти цю мову.
Це фантастика!
Ніби бажано було,
щоб нинішній урок закінчився тим,
щоб він після цього, що я його ганяю,
до мене сам підійшов.
Ми будуємо довіру один до одного.
І після того, як він до мене підійде,
я перестану з ним щось робити.
Він зрозуміє, що підійти до мене —
це означає розслабитись.
Ану побіжимо в другий бік, Хась.
То ми працюємо дистанцією і моїм положенням до нього.
Моя простягнута сюди рука,
а ця рука показує йому напрямок.
Тобто продовження моїх рук — є певні лінії.
От я, якщо роблю так,
то я так якби ставлю йому бар'єр з цього боку,
а цим показую, що я туди хочу.
Молодець!
Ми скінчили заняття на сьогодні.
Взагалі, все, що тут відбувається, — це якісь чудеса!
Я ніколи в житті не міг би подумати,
що я щось таке зможу збудувати,
і до того ж так швидко.
Я не знаю, звідки я взяв на це гроші,
і не знаю, де я взяв таких класних
людей, які мені допомагали.
Тут є якийсь надзвичайний скарб, тут усім добре!
Я не зустрічав людей, які би сюди приїжджали,
і не поверталися з якимсь спокоєм і задоволенням.
Тому я думаю, що це скарб.
Спокій — це ж найцінніший скарб.